committing to join a gigantic franchise
like the dc film franchise
is it's like a big different kind of
thing so
when you're considering whether or not
to sign on for a film like that
what new things do you have to keep in
your mind in order to make the best
possible decision
that might not be part of the
decision-making process before
well i had to look at the amount of time
that i had to be gone
i'm also the mom of a at that time only
10 year old boy
um who i could not just be away from
for you know five months
and so to the credit of warner brothers
they
just totally flew me back and forth
every week from san francisco to london
and i would be home they provided me at
home
with a coach uh a uh
a an actual bodybuilder coach uh
a sword coach and
um and then they flew me every sunday
back to uh to london
and then i'd go straight from the
airport to uh
work out and there was that moment
where you know i just all of a sudden
the the bag that i brought with me back
and forth
i could take it in one arm and i didn't
notice
that i had taken it in one arm and just
put it up there
like my carry-on with one arm
and i was just like this
is working i'm so
strong right now it's insane and
obviously
for my body rhythm it was completely
crazy and
ridiculous and yet i was just so
grateful
that the studio was so understanding of
you know the needs of a mother to to do
that while we were shooting such a huge
project and
patty was okay with everybody was okay
with it not only okay but so supportive
of it too i was like amazed
you